[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами сьогодні пані Соля
та мій помічник Совеня Ось тут я дорогі
мої друзі і знаєте про що ми сьогодні
будемо говорити я знаю бо я готувала для
вас заняття І зараз я вам підкажу
ми будемо говорити про щось Що навесні
здобуває листочки а восени їх скидає що
ж це може бути О я знаю це дерева так
дороге моє Совеня сьогодні будемо
говорити про дерева тож друзі Давайте ви
всі налаштуєте вушка очка і наша Совеня
з бочку собі сяде і буде слухати що ж
сьогодні будемо з вами розповідати Отож
перш за все Я хочу вам сказати що дерево
крім того що є
легенями землі пригадуйте ми колись
давно з вами про це говорили що
дерева
видихають кисень який життєво необхідний
людям і
вдихають вуглекислий газ вуглекислий газ
це та повітря яке ми люди видихаємо яке
нам не потрібно і завдяки такий чудовій
роботі дерев ми з вами можемо дихати
свіжим повітрям І взагалі вдихати кисень
який нам друзі необхідний для того аби
жити і крім того що дерева є легенями
землі бо саме дерева нам створюють
кисень окрім того що дерева є легенями
землі бо саме завдяки деревам ми
отримуємо кисень і можемо жити рухатись
та бігати спати їсти і пити окрім того з
дерев створюється
багато всього різного наприклад ось цей
олівець
або Ось ця книжка вона теж зроблена з
дерева
або ось цей годинник чи будь-яка інша
іграшка
створена з дерева або двері створені з
дерева стілець дерев'яний дерев'яний
дерев'яний стіл папір і багато інших
виробів які виготовляються з дерев окрім
паперу книжок дерев'яних меблів також на
деревах росте чай Ні не в таких
пакетиках але є чайне листя вона росте
на деревах і пізніше ми його отримуємо у
пакетики з чаю також шоколад у нас
знаєте звідки росте майже на деревах але
какао-боби з яких виготовляються шоколад
ростуть на деревах банани ростуть на
деревах апельсини лимони яблучко багато
що росте на деревах Тож сьогодні ми
поговоримо про дерева
Отож друзі перш за все що я хочу вам
сказати що потрібно для того аби росла
рослинка ви вже добре знаєте тому ми
зараз повторюємо потрібне сонце потрібен
дощик потрібно насінинка ґрунт тобто
земля і коли ми беремо насінинку і
садимо в грунт то глибоко в землю
проростає коріння
а сама насінинка росте
вгору спершу з маленького паростка а
потім у велике дерево і так цікаво
відбувається бо корінчики ростуть вниз а
це все відбувається завдяки силі земного
тяжіння пам'ятаєте ми вже з вами стільки
всього вивчили А листочки ростуть догори
бо тягнуться до сонечка бо сонечко як і
дощик є життєво необхідними для того аби
наша рослинка росла зеле
і здоровою і давали Нам багато кисню щоб
ми могли дихати ще таке друзі чи знаєте
ви чому
у нас
восени листочки жовтіють або червоніють
а влітку і весною вони у нас є зелені
Зараз я вам розкажу для того аби росла
рослинка нам потрібна сонце
І от у кожній рослинці є така спеціальна
фарба барвник який називається
хлорофіл давайте разом повторимо
хлорофіл
ця фарба барвник завдяки дії сонячного
промінчика
виділяє спеціальний сік
яким живиться наше дерево
і цей сік є необхідним для того аби
дерево зеленіло і росло
А давайте ж тепер подумаємо коли в нас є
найбільше сонця
влітку так і ще його стає все більше і
більше весною після зими і коли сонечко
стає багато то оцей барвник хлорофіл
який є в листочку його стає все більше і
більше і дерева суть все зеленіші
зеленіші
А що трапляється восени і взимку сонечко
багато чи мало Так друзі сонечко стає
менше
відповідно
хлорофіл оцей барвник його стає теж
менше І знаєте що тоді наш листок змінює
колір
оскільки значно менше є хлорофілу значно
менше виділяється соку завдяки якому
живиться дерево і
листок стає іншого кольору і щоб ви
знали друзі інші кольори завжди були
присутні у листочку просто через те що
сонце так багато
хлорофіл виділяє так багато соку
зеленого кольору було найбільше А коли
сонечко стає менше починають проявлятися
і інші кольори які завжди були у
листочку От наприклад друзі У мене в
руках є три листки І знаєте з якого це
дерево з лимонного дерева три листочки
два з них вже є жовтенькі опале а один
такий ще зелененький Ось так друзі Тепер
ви знаєте чому листя змінює колір тому
що на дерево потрапляє все менше
сонячного проміння Але у вас може
виникнути дуже добре питання
Чому наприклад єлинки залишаються
зеленими весь рік а зараз розкажу якщо
подивитися на ялиночку то Ялинка має
такі гострі гілочки і чи ці гілочки
схожі на наш листок чи ні Ні вони зовсім
іншої форми вони гострі тоненькі і
маленькі і саме завдяки формі хвойного
дерева бо ялинки і сосни дерева з
колючками це є хвойні дерева саме
завдяки формі такого листка хлорофіл
зберігається гарно у кожній голочці і
нікуди не зникає Ось так друзі А ще таке
цікавинка від пані солі чи знали ви що
найстаріше дерево на нашій планеті Який
ще росте на землі має п'ять тисяч років
Це дуже багато 5 тисяч років має дерево
найстаріше у світі друзі дуже багато
років що ми з вами стільки точно ще не
живемо я маю на увазі Я пані Соля ви
друзі і
наша Совеня Це є дуже багато Жодна
людина не прожила стільки років як
прожила наприклад дерево також
чи знаєте ви що
найвище дерево в світі
має висоту
сорокаповерхового будинку
це дуже багато от того якось як знайдете
такий найвищий будинок який буде поруч
порахуйте скільки там поверхів там точно
буде менше ніж 40 Я думаю таку Уявіть
собі наскільки високе дерево яке має 40
поверхів я бачила це дерево вживу і
чесно друзі я не могла до кінця побачити
де воно закінчується таке воно високе
було уявляєте Ось така історія друзів
Отож ми будемо з вами закінчувати Але
перед тим Я маю для вас домашні завдання
подумайте що ще може виготовлятися з
дерева можливо навколо вас є якісь
цікаві і іграшки речі зошити меблі і
перелічіть Разом з дорослими які є біля
вас які з предметів що вас оточують
виготовляються з дерева
Ось так друзі Тож давайте тепер покаємо
наше Совеня яке злетіло з якогось дерева
до нас в гості правда Совеня
Совеня Де ти Де ти Де ти Я тут прилетіло
зі свого улюбленого дубочка так друзі Я
думаю вам було цікаво чому листя змінює
колір А чому якийсь дерева не змінюють
колір і що взагалі утворюється з дерева
Я думаю ми можемо досліджувати це
довго-довго і цікаво маєте домашнє
завдання правда
правда будемо тепер прощатися будемо
програма
папа друзі до наступного разу
[музика]
Привіт друзі Всім привіт з вами
науковець Соломія
Сьогодні ми експериментуємо а насправді
я вам покажу
як дихає листок
пригадуєте Ми говорили з вами про те
наскільки Важливо щоб було чисте повітря
що було багато кисню бо це для нас людей
є неймовірно корисно і важливо і
важливою потрібно для життя так от Ось у
мене є звичайний листок я його зірвала з
дерева друзі Ви так робіть лише у
випадку якщо вам дуже необхідно в
жодному іншому разі не робіть листки з
дерев бо вони нам необхідні для того щоб
очищувати повітря і дихати от Я зірвала
листок і
листок який я теж зірвала Я помістила у
склянку
ні щойно помістили у склянку і набрала
зверху води тепер друзі Ми можемо з вами
побачити в дуже простий спосіб як дихає
листок От наприклад юстенко ти коли
пірнаєш або занурюєшся під воду коли ти
видихаєш що йде з твого рота бульбашки
бульбашки Так ми видихаємо і під водою
видно бульбашки тому що коли ми дихаємо
на поверхні землі ж не видно що ми
дихаємо правда А от під водою видно як
ці бульбашки з нас виринають дзеркало ще
коли ти стрибаєш бомбочкою угоди тоді
там теж бульбашки під низом і вони тебе
можуть розкатати так але давай варимось
до нашого експерименту глянь будь ласка
на листок що ти бачиш на ньому
бульбашки маленькі багато дуже багато
бульбашок друзів це означає що листок
теж дихає по-справжньому Бо знаєте ви
могли думати як же ж так дерева дихають
Та нічого вони не дихають бо я цього не
бачу але завдяки тому що ми набрали воду
і помістили всередину листок ми бачимо
скільки навколо утворилося бульбашок і
це означає що листок дихає тому друзі
так важливо
вирощувати рослинки підливати в вазонки
і садити нові дерева Оскільки ми чітко
бачимо що листки справді дихають і
справді очищують наших повітря Ось так
друзі
на цьому сьогодні Все можете спробувати
самостійно зробити цей простий
експеримент і побачите Як ваші листки
також дихають
домовились Ну що ж
гарного вам дня друзі па-па
[музика]